and president Trump showed no signs of
backing down at his promise to build a
border wall at a rally in Richfield Ohio
today drugs are flowing across borders
we need walls we started building our
wall I'm so proud of it we've already
started you saw the pictures yesterday I
said what a thing of beauty and on
September 28th we go further and we're
getting that sucker built and you think
that's easy people said Oh has he given
up on the one I never give up
there are even reports that the
president is considering having the
military pay for the wall through the
military budget joining me now for
reaction was tenant Colonel Michael
walls colonel waltz this is this is a
wild situation now the president said
that today that it's already
construction is already underway though
I think it was the Washington Post might
bend the New York Times tonight said
that's just not true
nothing's underway so I don't know what
he's talking about
meanwhile the American people are
wondering what's going on with with
national security with the humanitarian
problem with the economic problem the
strain on our budgets you see what's
going on in California the homelessness
why can't we enforce our border is there
no will to do it I think the president
has a will but Congress doesn't seem to
well Laura first you know the president
is absolutely right
border security is a national security
issue look a pipeline that can move
immigrants and can move drugs can also
move WMD can move terrorists and can
move weapons and we know that Hezbollah
is all over South Central America is
working with Mexican drug gangs
Hezbollah operative was convicted in
2011 for working with the Mexican drug
gang the Zetas in order to smuggle
explosives in and assassinate the Saudi
ambassador in Washington DC so he's
absolutely right subsidy and in fact the
Department of the defense and military
both National Guard and active duty are
supporting ice are supporting CBP and
are supporting law enforcement all up
and down our border the issue here is is
paying for it and in order to reprogram
funds you have to go
back to Congress you can move relatively
small amounts but in order to move
billions like what is estimated to build
the wall then you're gonna have to go
back to Congress and it's unclear there
whether he'll have the support it should
have been negotiated in the current bill
yeah I mean it's so infuriating on like
multiple levels that that was not an
absolute must in the Omnibus but we know
kernel debt Paul Ryan Mitch McConnell
and many others in leadership and and
other kind of mainstream Republicans
they didn't want a wall they didn't want
a wall they're happy with sensors or
drones and fences fixed here and there
they do not want a wall they don't like
the imagery of the wall they think it
makes us look like you know you know
East Germany they don't want it they
they never wanted it Trump ran on it and
won in part on that one large part on
that wall and I think come hell or high
water he's got to make sure that thing's
built for his own political future and
for the country safety more importantly
we know Laura there is this interesting
question of can he declare this a
national emergency of what's going on on
our border and you know much like what
happens in a hurricane or in another
natural disaster or riots and
federalized troops federalized the
National Guard and use them in this case
but again what happens in those cases is
there's a quick conversation with
Congress and and and the president moves
forward under his executive authority
and then they appropriate it later so
you know there is a lot of discussion of
whether he can just declare this a
national emergency and do it but again
you've got you think they're gonna tie
him up in the courts and you've got
procreation you've got gonna fight this
you're gonna sue they're gonna try to
sue the administration a preliminary
injunction that injunctive relief
stopped him from doing that it's gonna
get all tied up you know the end of the
day he's absolutely right but it should
have been negotiated in the bill you
have the power of the purse and you know
mattis I mean I can't imagine mattis is
wild about this they talked about it
apparently the spokesman confirmed that
it was discussed I think they're running
it past the General Council I think
that's window dressing to kind of
placate the president mattis doesn't
want a wall I think Donald Trump is one
of the few people left in the entire
administration that real
wants a wall and his instinct about this
stuff is always right he is the best
political instinct on most of the
substance Congress still hasn't caught
up to him so well Tang Bao Dee can go
back and reprogram these funds he can
tell deep mat general mattis you're
gonna do it you're gonna go back and
then they can refight this on in in
Congress to reprogram their spines I
think they should do that but there's a
notion that he won't have to go back to
the Congress and you and to my knowledge
you have to yeah Colonel Walt's the
thing about this is that Congress has
basically said they're not gonna do
anything for the rest of the year until
I guess the next budget fight comes
around in the fall so they're really not
gonna do anything so we're gonna watch
them go on vacation for two weeks naming
some libraries I'm not gonna do much so
why not take that thing take the
substantive fight to Congress make them
defend the fact that they want to leave
our southern border open I think I think
that's a great fight for Trump to take
and I think his instinct is great well
close it out and no and and he
absolutely can do that he can order to
you D to do it he can order DHS to do it
under his executive authority again I
want to emphasize the military is
already out there supporting this effort
in doing a fantastic job but you just
can't you know you can't decide you want
less planes and more ships and just move
funds but stick it back on Congress and
make them do their job all right thank
you so much